[Music]
hi I'm Danny Rand I've been away a long
time let's go you don't belong here
I'm Danny Rand guys I just want to talk
[Music]
welcome to ranch enterprises I left here
ten years old and a jet to my parents i
became the lone survivor Danny Rand back
from the dead why didn't waited this
long to show up how the hell did he
learn martial arts where'd you train
come on
my father instilled in me a love and
respect for this company that has never
faded this is my home
Rand is my company this city is no place
for Danny
we put spring now give it up no covenant
or many what happened to you why are you
really back here some bad people have
gotten on the inside criminals I know
what they are but they can do
to fight them we need someone with
special skills I've been training my
whole life for this this is my bestie
it's time
I'm going with you no you're not you
need me the change is coming down become
what you were meant to be
I am the iron fist how does that mean
okay what's that he says welcome to the
frickin guardians of the galaxy